ROSE CRANBERRY: (STATIC)
So, Petey,
I just want you to read
this part right here
-that I have circled.
-PETEY: Okay.
All right, right.
Wait, am I gonna get credit
-for this?
-ROSE: Credit?
There is no credit,
just read the lines.
-Just-- Stop.
-PETEY:
You not gonna put this on IMDB?
ROSE: No, no.
Petey, don't be a weirdo.
-Stop.
-PETEY: Let me put on
-my good shirt.
-ROSE: I'm counting down,
and five, four, three,
two...
PETEY: What button do I press
to start recording?
ROSE: Oh, my God,
Petey.
It's already on.
PETEY: Oh, well...
ROSE: (SIGHS)
Can you please
just read the paper?
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
PETEY: The following documents
the events surrounded
by a missing person's
investigation.
This investigation
was conducted by family,
friends, a bitch-ass
police department.
Ooh, I hate the police,
I really do.
I told you they tried
to tell me
I can't bring my raccoon
to the dog park.
ROSE: Petey! Petey!
Stop talking, go, thanks.
-PETEY: (FALTERS)
-ROSE: Go!
PETEY: Just like the police.
ROSE: (SIGHS)
Whatever.
Sorry about that.
That's my cousin, Petey.
He agreed to let me stay here
with him in LA
while I conduct
my investigation.
As long as I let him help me out
from time to time.
But... okay, here we go.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
The following documents
the events surrounded
by a missing person's
investigation.
This investigation
was conducted by family,
friends, a bitch-ass
police department, and myself,
Rose Cranberry.
Who is not a journalist
by any means.
This is Looking for LaToya.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
WOMAN: She was so sweet.
Kind of a bird, but so sweet.
WOMAN 2: I told her black ass
to never leave Atlanta.
I heard Cali be on
that bullshit.
MAN: I mean, yeah,
we went to prom together.
But we haven't talked
in years.
I thought she been dead.
WOMAN 3: I don't think
she dead.
She chillin' with 'Pac
and them.
MAN 2: You know
they ain't looking.
Nobody cares when our girls
go missing.
WOMAN 4: Mm-hmm.
See? That's why I don't go
to Red Lobster.
No one ever goes missing
from Chili's.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
ROSE: Remotes,
bobby pins, socks,
a favorite V-neck...
All the replaceable things
that we tend to fret over
when they are lost
or simply misplaced.
But when it comes
to missing black girls,
it's a topic often overlooked.
No one checks the crevices
of the couch, behind the dryer,
the junk drawer.
It seems as though
these missing black girls
are just... forgotten.
And it's nothing new.
This has been an issue
for years.
And think about it...
We still haven't found
the original dark-skinned Claire
from My Wife and Kids.
(SIGHS) But that's
another podcast.
This podcast is about
26-year-old LaToya Thompson.
-(DOOR CREAKS OPEN)
-PETEY: Hey, Rose...
-You seen my Texas toast?
-(ROSE GROANS)
-(DOOR CLOSES)
-(POTS AND PANS CLANG)
ROSE:
For the last nine years,
I've proudly served
as the certified
theft specialist
and chief investigative officer
for Burlington Coat Factory
back in Atlanta, Georgia.
Although it's just called
Burlington now.
Anyway... My job
has always required me
to have a very keen sense
of detail.
After years of monitoring
both entrance and exit doors,
screening hardcore criminals,
reviewing top-secret
security footage, and binging
Law and Order repeats...
There's not much
that can get past me.
I pay attention to things.
I notice things.
("LAW AND ORDER"
TONE PLAYS)
See at Burlington,
we have an array of customers.
But we also have
our committed regulars,
who frequent the store
on a weekly basis.
One of those people
was Glenda Thompson.
Glenda typically came in
once a week
to browse linens
and stock up on scented candles.
Oftentimes,
she'd be accompanied
by her 26-year-old
daughter, LaToya.
They were both so friendly.
And always smiling,
and made sure to greet me.
We even spoke from time
to time.
I remember the day Glenda
came in alone.
And she told me that LaToya
had moved to Los Angeles
to be a star.
Which came as no surprise
to me because I'd often
see LaToya twerking
for the store cameras.
(TAPE REEL SPINS CHAOTICALLY)
(OVERLAPPING CHATTER, CHEERING)
But after a few weeks,
I noticed something
had changed with Glenda.
She stopped greeting me.
Her linen selection got lazy.
Her smile had completely faded.
It looked as though something
was weighing on her.
Something heavy.
So I approached her
with a few questions.
(TAPE DECK CLICKING)
INTERCOM: Attention shoppers,
Burlington will be closing
in 15 minutes.
GLENDA: All I really know
is that she moved in
with a girl named Tasha.
Said she signed up
for some overpriced
acting class,
taught by a renowned actor.
But I couldn't even find him
on Google.
She started fooling
with some guy named Rufus,
and said he was on his way
to being one
of those influencers.
She mentioned something
about his teeth.
Um, they're loose, or dead,
maybe both.
I knew we should have never
let her leave Atlanta.
ROSE: Glenda went on
to tell me
she hadn't heard from LaToya
in quite some time.
She was officially announced
as missing,
and had been since July 23rd.
The last place she'd been
seen was at a Red Lobster
in Inglewood, California.
That's when...
PETEY: I found the Texas toast.
Rose, you want some Texas--
ROSE: No! Petey! Damn,
can't you see I'm on--
I'm recording.
(SIGHS)
Sorry.
Like I was saying,
that's when I knew I had
to help.
Glenda explained to me
that LaToya was missing,
and to no surprise,
no one seemed to care.
I felt with all my experience
in resolving shoplifting cases,
catching petty criminals,
and assessing missing items,
it was a chance for me
to step up.
It was time for me
to do something more important
than loss prevention:
lost girls prevention.
But just the black ones.
The white ones are fine.
That's when I decided
to pursue my own investigation,
make my way to Los Angeles
and start this podcast.
I've also been told
that I have a good radio voice.
I've occasionally been asked
to make
the intercom announcements
in the department store.
(INTERCOM FEEDBACK)
(OVER INTERCOM) Leanne,
you're needed at the register.
Leanne, needed at the register.
(CLOCK TICKING)
(SIPPING DRINK, CLEARS THROAT)
Biscuits...
Cheddar Bay Biscuits.
A convenient and delicious
luxury for many.
But for LaToya,
it might have been
the bite between life and death.
Who's responsible?
Did anyone see this coming?
Could anyone have stopped it?
Is LaToya just missing?
-Or was she... murdered?
-(SCREAMING)
I was determined to find out.
When I arrived in LA,
I decided
to start my investigation
Jehovah-Witness style,
going door-to-door
in LaToya's neighborhood.
(BIRDS CHIRPING)
(KNOCKING ON DOOR)
-(DOOR CREAKS OPEN)
-Have you seen this girl?
MAN: Nah, have you?
ROSE: No, that's
why I was ask--
-(DOOR SHUTS)
-Okay.
-(DOGS BARKING)
-(KNOCKING ON DOOR)
-(DOOR CREAKS OPEN)
-ROSE: Hi, have you seen--
WOMAN: I done told
y'all motherfuckers,
I ain't selling my house.
-(NEIGHBORS CHATTERING)
-(KNOCKING ON DOOR)
(DOOR CREAKS OPEN)
♪ (LOUD HIP-HOP MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
ROSE: Uh, hi!
Does this girl look familiar
-to you?
-MAN: Oh, shit.
Ain't that the original
little sister
from My Wife and Kids?
The dark-skinned one?
I'm glad she good.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
ROSE: No.
No that was not
the original sister
from My Wife and Kids,
it was LaToya.
After spending hours
checking all the
low-income apartments
in the Inglewood area,
I was finally able
to track down
where LaToya lived.
For a small exchange fee,
which I won't elaborate on,
the landlord gave me
both LaToya
and her roommate Tasha's
contact info.
Of course, I called LaToya
to no avail.
-(DIAL TONE BEEPING)
-SPOKESPERSON: We're sorry,
the customer you are trying
to reach
is currently unavailable.
Please hang up and try again.
ROSE: I then dialed
Tasha,
hoping to get an answer.
TASHA: (OVER VOICEMAIL)
You've reached Tasha!
I ain't here, so you know
what to do, leave it.
-(VOICEMAIL BEEPING)
-ROSE: Hi, Tasha,
this is Rose Cranberry.
I'm calling about your roommate,
LaToya Thompson.
Please call me back
as soon as you can,
as I'm trying to gather
some information
on her acting coach,
or the friend
with the dead teeth.
Hope to hear from you soon,
thanks.
Much like the current state
of my hair,
I had hit another dead end.
So far I was getting nowhere.
(CLOCK TICKING)
(TAPE REEL SPINNING)
TRAVIS: I knew something
was up
when she came in
with the white boy.
STACY: Mm-hmm.
Her "acting coach."
They came for the
cheddar biscuits after class.
(TAPE REEL STOPS SPINNING)
ROSE: The voices
you just heard
are that of two Red Lobster
employees, Travis and Stacy,
who claim to have seen
LaToya last.
I was able to sit down
with them both.
TRAVIS: It was weird 'cause,
you know,
white people don't ever go
to the Inglewood Red Lobster.
They always complain
the music's too loud.
STACY: Yeah.
Unless they tourists,
and trying to experience
the hood.
They usually go
to the one in Torrance.
TRAVIS: Plus,
we always out of salmon.
They hate that.
ROSE: I see. So tell me
what you saw that day.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
STACY: Well...
They was just sitting
at the bar like they always do.
ROSE: So this was
a regular thing?
STACY: Yep.
They came in like once a week.
But this time he was
looking suspicious.
ROSE: And why is that?
STACY: He was wearing a hoodie.
TRAVIS: And he was drinking
a Sprite with no ice.
That's serial killer shit.
ROSE: I see.
I was told LaToya had
a boyfriend.
Do you think it's safe
to say
that she was having an affair
with this guy?
TRAVIS:
Man, I ain't no damn snitch.
But I definitely think
he hit it.
Ain't nobody just gone buy you
biscuits without some booty.
And she always looked
hella happy.
WOMAN: Yeah, but this time,
he rushed out all quick.
I think he left right when
the biscuits came.
So, she was just sitting there
alone
with a basket full of biscuits,
looking all inspired and shit.
ROSE:
And how long would you say
LaToya sat there
before she left?
WOMAN: I don't know.
Maybe like 20 minutes.
She was gone when I came back
from my break.
I went to Carl's Jr.
(CLOCK TICKING)
ROSE: After learning
this tasty tidbit,
I knew it was time for me
to have a talk
with this Cheddar Bae.
It took a while for me
to get in touch with him
as he was on tour doing
a monologue series
in conjunction
with Reese Witherspoon
and Ice Cube.
CHEDDAR BAE: I met LaToya
in the acting class I teach.
We once reenacted a scene
from The Player's Club together.
She was not a good actor,
but she was very beautiful
and had the biggest heart.
ROSE: Would you say you two
were dating?
BAE:
Well, yeah. We loved each other.
We had a pretty deep connection.
I've always had an appreciation
for colored women like LaToya.
-ROSE: Colored?
-BAE: She was special.
I left my wife for her.
ROSE:
I-- I'm sorry. You're married?
BAE: Well, not anymore.
ROSE: Okay...
Um, tell me about your weekly
Red Lobster dates.
BAE: One day after class,
she asked me
to give her some notes
on her voice inflections.
You know, like, "I never said
he owed me money"
versus "I never said
he owed me money."
So I agreed to help her out.
She suggested Red Lobster
since it was near her house.
That just became our go-to spot.
ROSE: Mm-hmm.
BAE: It was really cool
to see the area she lived.
It was very lively.
I'd never been
to the Red Lobster on Century.
-MAN: Y'all stay out my set.
-(GLASS SHATTERING)
(INDISTINCT ARGUING,
LAUGHING)
BAE: I'd always gone to the one
on Torrance.
ROSE: Can you tell me exactly
what happened
at this July 23rd lunch?
BAE: I went,
but I couldn't stay long.
I had to miss lunch
for a big audition.
But it was worth it.
I got a call back
for the Simi Valley Junior
College Repertory Theater's
production of
Sons of Anarchy: The Musical.
I did not get the part.
But now, they know me.
ROSE: Congratulations.
BAE: Thanks! She was
really intrigued by my success.
She just kept saying,
"Wait, and you'll see.
Someday, I'll be a part
of your world."
Anyway, I've been looking
for her, too.
(SIGHS) But a new black girl
just enrolled in the class,
so it's fine
if you can't find her.
We still meet
our diversity quota.
(CLOCK TICKING)
ROSE:
As nice as it would have been
to be able to blame
the white man,
Cheddar Bae's story checked out.
I spoke to the dean of the
Simi Valley Junior College
Repertory Theater
and Cheddar Bae did indeed
audition that day.
And he did not get the part.
But I knew there was more
to this.
Did LaToya have a secret?
Was she hiding something?
I knew there was only one person
who would have these answers:
the person closest to LaToya,
her roommate, Tasha,
who had finally returned
my call.
TASHA: Hey, Rose, my bad.
I'm just now calling you back.
I was watching Boosie
on Instagram Live,
and you know, lost track
of time.
I be so busy, but I'm free
to come talk to you tomorrow.
I honestly feel like
it's her boyfriend.
He's a suspect and ain't nobody
questioning that nigga.
You can text me the time and
address, and I will be there.
You ain't gotta call me back.
ROSE: I was happy
to finally hear from Tasha.
Knowing her information
could potentially bring us
one step closer
to finding LaToya.
(CLOCK TICKING)
Tasha, can you explain
your relationship with LaToya?
TASHA: We've been roommates
ever since she moved to LA.
We became friends after we met
at Bill Bellamy's house.
It was Taco Tuesday.
ROSE: How close are you guys?
TASHA:
She would tell me everything
and she was always there
when I needed somebody
to talk to.
ROSE: I know LaToya had
a boyfriend.
Can you tell me
about that relationship?
TASHA:
Um... Well, in the beginning,
everything was great.
She'd tell me how special
he made her feel.
He would give her all
of his attention.
He would never check his phone
when they were together.
She never even heard it vibrate.
She said he always kept it face
down out of respect for her.
I was happy for her
and I couldn't wait to find me
a man to treat me the same way.
ROSE: Hmm...
When do you think such
a beautiful relationship
took a turn?
TASHA: It was something
about social media.
He would make her delete
any video
where you could hear his voice
or see his arm.
ROSE:
And what was the last thing
she said about him?
TASHA: Well, she told me her
and her boyfriend
were having problems.
They was always arguing.
ROSE: Did you see anything
that would make you think
he was a suspect?
TASHA:
Well... this particular day
I was in my car, I looked
out the window,
and I was like,
"Nah, that don't look right."
It looked dangerous. I know
he know something. Did he do it?
ROSE: You do know Cheddar Bae
was the last person she was with
before she went missing, right?
TASHA: Yeah, I know
about that white boy,
but I still think it's Rufus!
A nigga with deceased teeth
is always a suspect.
(SOBBING)
It just-- It just like--
I really miss my friend.
I wanna help look, I do,
but my tags on my car,
they expired and all that.
You're our only hope, Rose.
Please.
ROSE: We will find her.
(CLOCK TICKING)
I knew the only way
I could solve this case
was to talk to this boyfriend
Rufus.
And like I said before,
I've seen enough Law and Order
to know there's always
a suspicious boyfriend.
(LAW AND ORDER TONE PLAYS)
RUFUS: Boyfriend?
Whoa, whoa, chill, chill.
Y'all gotta chill with that.
She said that?
Look, I mean, (CHUCKLES)
we were talkin'.
All right, did I hit?
Yeah, I hit,
but I didn't kill her though.
I mean, I killed the pussy,
but... (CHUCKLES)
Um, but, uh... my condolences
to her moms and pops, though.
I don't know where she at, man.
ROSE: I sat down with Tasha.
RUFUS: She always runnin'
her mouth.
ROSE: She told me you and LaToya
had conflicts over social media.
Can you expand on that.
RUFUS: Man, I don't even have
a social media account, bruh.
Real P stay off the scene.
Always ten toes,
hardly even seen.
You understand what I'm sayin?
ROSE: Actually, I don't.
RUFUS: You know what kills me?
ROSE: What kills you, Rufus?
RUFUS: Her claiming that I was
her boyfriend
like she deserved to be wifed.
She couldn't even support
a nigga dreams, man.
She wanted me to play T.I.
and practice that
"Give Me My Chain Back" scene
from ATL
for her acting class, right.
Bruh, I hate that movie.
And she ain't Lauren London
either.
(CHUCKLES) I tell ya that much.
Why would I care about that
if she can't post some shit
to help me to make some money?
Does that make any sense?
All right?
Does that sound like somebody
I would make my girl?
ROSE:
What did you want her to post?
RUFUS: I just wanted her
to ask her followers
who got Chase, Cash App
or Venmo?
Y'all got Cash App? Y'all got
Venmo? Y'all got Chase?
That's it.
You know, I was gon' put
some money in they account
and take a little bit
off the top.
ROSE: That is a crime.
But I see that you're upset.
Is that what you were arguing
about at the mall?
RUFUS: I'm not upset, all right.
Don't try to paint that picture.
That day, I was slippin'.
Super slippin'.
I mean, we were pulling up
to the mall,
she grabbed my phone,
and it was unlocked. Okay?
Then she seen that my alerts
was off
and she saw my work
hitting me up
about a bunch
of different things.
ROSE: Work.
So, you were cheating.
RUFUS: My work-- Look.
(STAMMERS)
Look, this ain't about me.
That was the last time
I seen her missin' ass. Period.
And I know
about the acting coach, too.
Yeah, y'all need to be going
to check him.
Find out some shit about him.
Always focused on the black man.
ROSE: Rufus. Where were you
the night she went missing?
I was recording a live podcast
for all my hustlers out there.
Okay, the shit was live.
Yeah, Superknit. Swoop!
You can check it out, too,
on onthecomeup.net.
All right, it got hella views.
Hella views, like, 19, 20.
ROSE: Nineteen or 20,000?
Million?
RUFUS: Nah, just 19 or 20.
T-- To be exact.
But the link is still up though,
if y'all wanna go check it out.
ROSE: Talking to Rufus was...
well, a headache.
But he did make me
realize something.
Maybe I wasn't looking
hard enough,
maybe there was something
I was missing.
Then it hit me.
Rufus!
Pronounced Roof-us.
Roof. LaToya was raised
under her parents' roof.
How could I have missed that?
This development meant
it was time to talk to Glenda
and Bryan
for more
of LaToya's origin story.
Maybe they knew something more.
Although they were hesitant
about speaking with me
and hate airplanes,
I was finally able
to convince them to come out
to LA for a sit down.
I offered Glenda a Burlington
gift card,
and she was able to clear
their schedule immediately.
GLENDA: Our LaToya
has always had big dreams
-of living in Los Angeles.
-BRYAN: Yeah, yeah,
she's always wanted to be a star
ever since
she was a little girl.
GLENDA:
But we told her she was already
a star in our eyes.
She had already accomplished
so much.
She starred as an extra
in a Rack Room Shoes commercial
a few years ago.
Um, I think it was a Rack Room.
BRYAN: Yeah, it was.
It was Rack Room. Mm-hmm.
Yeah, you could see
my baby's ankle real clear.
-I know my baby's ankle.
-GLENDA: Mm-hmm.
And after that, she became
an ambassador
for Blue Magic Hair Grease,
even spoke on a panel
about it.
ROSE: Oh, that-- That's big.
BRYAN: Exactly. That's what
I'm talking about.
I mean, my baby ain't never been
one to just disappear on us.
GLENDA: She told us everything.
Even about that raggedy ass boy,
Rufus.
I don't know how
she got involved with him.
Bryan taught LaToya
at a young age
to never get involved
with a man
-who only owns one towel.
-BRYAN: Man, I sure did.
I'm sayin' I used to be
that nigga, so I know.
GLENDA: Mm-hmm.
ROSE: Is there anything specific
LaToya mentioned about Rufus
to make you so certain he was
involved in her disappearance?
GLENDA: Mm-hmm. See, she told me
that one time,
Rufus asked her to marry him
right quick so he could be added
to her dental insurance.
She said no,
and he didn't like that.
Then, she said he got upset
and threatened to throw
chicken nuggets at her.
ROSE: Oh, no!
GLENDA: He did it. I know it
in my heart he did it.
BRYAN: Whoa, whoa, baby,
now come on. We don't know that.
Okay, we don't know that
for sure. We don't know that.
All we can do is just have faith
and-- and pray. Look, I--
I know my baby's out there
somewhere
and we not gon' give up.
GLENDA: If anybody, anybody
has any information at all
please don't hesitate
to come forward.
Any little thing will help me.
Any snapchat photos,
any Instagrams, whatever
you got on that little nigga,
(CRYING)
I don't trust his ass!
ROSE: It was clear to me
that no one seemed to trust
Rufus's ass.
And it was starting to feel like
I was hitting a wall.
Travis and Stacey both saw Gabe,
the Cheddar Bae,
leave Red Lobster before LaToya.
Gabe's audition for
Sons of Anarchy: The Musical
checks out.
Tasha's tags are
definitely expired.
And there's nothing
pointing in her direction
as a suspect.
I did however follow up
on Rufus's podcast alibi,
and he was telling the truth,
except about one little thing.
There were only 14 views
on that podcast,
not nearly 19 or 20.
But unfortunately
a sorry podcast
doesn't make you a murderer.
(DOOR SLOWLY CREAKING OPEN)
PETEY: Psst, Rose!
You recording?
ROSE: Yes, Petey, what?
PETEY: My spork set is missing.
You seen it?
ROSE: (SIGHS) No, I haven't,
I haven't seen it.
LaToya's still missing too!
PETEY: Still? Damn.
(DOOR CREAKS CLOSED)
ROSE: It was time I tried
my luck with a higher authority:
the inner city
police department.
I met with the lead detective
on the case,
to try and get some answers.
-(PHONE RINGING)
-POLICE OFFICER:
I don't know what to tell ya.
We have put
as many resources
as we can towards
finding Toyota.
We put her photo up,
all around the city.
We've held several press
conferences.
ROSE: I went out and attended
one of these press conferences.
OFFICER: I wanna assure
the good people of Los Angeles
that we are doing everything
in our power to ensure
the safe return of this lost
Toyota.
REPORTER: Sir, again,
this is the case
about the missing
African American girl,
LaToya Thompson,
not a missing vehicle.
OFFICER:
No further comment at this time.
(REPORTERS CHATTERING)
ROSE: I wanted to catch up
with this reporter
as she seemed to be
just as dedicated to this case
as I was.
Unfortunately, by the time
the press conference ended,
she too had been reported
missing.
(SIGHS)
I can't find everyone.
I just can't. I-- I-- I'm tired.
I can't.
(CLOCK TICKING)
After running out of ideas,
I knew there was one last place
I could turn.
A place that was sure to have
a black woman's best interest
at heart.
I decided to go to a local
Inglewood hair salon
where LaToya frequented.
And honestly,
I needed a trim.
To no surprise, the girl
who cuts hair wasn't available,
because she too
had gone missing.
Very inconvenient for me.
But...
anyway, I got the salon
up to speed on the case,
I gave them a rundown
of all the evidence
and interviews I've collected
so far.
(SHOP BELL DINGS)
STYLIST:
Y'all know who did it right?
That white man!
You know they crazy. Just like
all them Lifetime movies.
ROSE: But his story checks out.
I called the college
about his audition.
STYLIST: Did the person
who answered the phone
sound white?
ROSE: Maybe. I'm-- I'm not sure.
STYLIST: Mmm. There it is,
you can't trust a white man!
Even if his story check out.
You know they all work together.
That girl is dead.
STYLIST 2:
No, no, no, it was Rufus.
You sound like just the rest
of these bum-ass LA dudes.
Girl, hire you
a private investigator
to follow Rufus. I can give you
the number to one now,
he been following both
my niggas for a week.
ROSE: I don't think that
will be necessary.
STYLIST 1:
Well, I think she's still alive.
What you need to do is set up
your own tip line.
Those police don't care.
It's our job to find her,
before she winds up
under the sea,
or on some wig chart
like the rest of them.
(CLOCK TICKING)
ROSE: She was right.
We do have to find her.
The last thing we need
is LaToya's face plastered
on a wig chart in a run-down
beauty supply store.
We can't give up!
I won't let us.
So I took her advice,
and started
a tip line of my own.
I made a Facebook page too,
where all black gossip lives.
And after just two weeks,
the calls were rolling in.
ROSE: (VOICEMAIL MESSAGE)
Thank you for calling She Lost,
where our number-one priority
is bringing LaToya home.
Please leave your name,
number,
and any information you may have
after the beep.
(RECORDING TONE)
Hello, uh, my name is Crystal
and I think I just saw LaToya
at the swing stop in Inglewood.
I'm here waiting for
my garlic wings,
and this nigga with a dead tooth
tried to talk to me.
After I gave him my number,
I seen him go to his car
and there was a girl
in the passenger seat.
I couldn't tell what she looked
like,
but I remember him
from your Facebook ads.
That's all the info I got.
So, do not call me back.
(RECORDING TONE)
This is Jessica,
I just seen your flyer
outside the bowling alley.
I don't know who LaToya is,
but can you put flyers up of me?
I want niggas looking
for me too.
(RECORDING TONE)
Hey, Rose!
Petey from downstairs,
your cousin.
No LaToya but I found
my spork set!
-You wouldn't believe where--
-(RECORDING TONE)
Yo, this Mike. I think I have
some info that could help you
find this LaToya chick.
Is there a reward though?
If so, call me back.
(CLOCK TICKING)
ROSE: After going through these
voicemails,
I decided to give Mike
a call back.
After I lied and told him
there was a reward,
he finally provided me
with some key information.
(DIALING PHONE NUMBER)
(PHONE RINGING)
MIKE: Before I say shit,
I need that reward, ASAP.
I'll text you my PayPal info.
ROSE: No problem, I'll have
my assistant Petey handle it.
Cool. Okay, so look.
I was taking my side piece
on a date out in Long Beach,
it's safe out there so I knew
nobody was gonna see me.
It was the same night
you said old girl went missing!
Anyway, we were walking up
past the docks.
Shorty I was with had never seen
docks before
so she was all like,
"Ooh, docks!"
That's when I saw LaTisha.
ROSE: LaToya.
MIKE: Whatever.
But there she was,
all by herself-- (PHONE STATIC)
ROSE:
Thanks to Mike's alertness,
and more importantly,
his infidelity,
he was able to provide
some very helpful tips.
We're now one step closer
to finding our beloved LaToya.
Updates coming soon.
Until then,
thanks for listening.
I'm Rose Cranberry,
and I'll see you
on the next installment of
Looking for LaToya.
Looking for LaToya
is a Rose Cranberry production.
Created, hosted, produced
and edited by me,
Rose Cranberry.
If you have questions, comments
or any further information,
please leave me a message.
I'd like to thank my
Burlington Coat Factory family,
Red Lobster, the Inglewood
Hair Salon,
and the family and friends
of LaToya Thompson,
for their participation
in this investigation.
Oh, and of course,
my cousin Petey,
for his um, help
and accommodations.
But I purposely
did not mention
the police...
with their bitch-asses.
ISSA RAE:
Thank you for listening
to Looking for LaToya.
We came up with the idea
for this series
in the Insecure writer's room
as a satirical way to highlight
the plight of missing
black women.
But that's not a joke.
And that's why Radio Tenderfoot
and HBO are proud to support
the Black and Missing
Foundation.
The Black and Missing Foundation
is a nonprofit organization
founded in 2008
by Natalie Wilson
and Derrica Wilson, to help
bring awareness to
an invisible group:
our missing.
Their mission is to
bring awareness
to the hundreds of thousands
of missing brown and black
men, women and children,
to search for those missing,
and to educate our community
on personal safety.
Since its inception,
the Black and Missing Foundation
has supported and provided
access to resources
for thousands of families
searching for
missing loved ones.
Their efforts have helped locate
more than 300 missing persons.
But with your support,
so many more can return home.
Let's all, the media,
law enforcement,
and the community, do our part
to help us find us.
Visit bamfi.org
to join the movement to
#helpusfindus.
It only takes one person
to come forward with information
to help solve the case.